[Musique]
elle te suit une question bonjour je
m'appelle d'années dans un de ses tweets
géraldine maillet a écrit que la
popularité des îles deux choses soit la
notoriété soit la positivité les
sentiments donc je voulais savoir qu'est
ce qu'est le fou dans votre émission
c'est une très très très bonne question
dany en fait on sait pas exactement
jardiner est arrivé dans l'émission en
stage d'observation et depuis elle reste
au départ elles étaient là pour nous
apporter un peu de culture car c'est
vrai que quand on écoute les
conversations entre certains on se dit
qu'il ya pas que des prix nobel dans
l'équipe
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu avais que j'expose il a dit non mais
sans déconner et elle me le disent
toujours ton pote ça n'a jamais été mon
pote c'est vrai hillman tout temps comme
ça même quand tu es moi c'est ça alicia
vous aller dans des expositions parfois
des expos stagiaires les expos six
navires non non on n'irait à la
bibliothèque ou non mais j'ai important
tony non mais là on est passé pas de
meilleur vous allez dans quel expo
géraldine maillet regarder va nous
déprimer non mais quand je vois je pense
à baudelaire baudelaire le voter le
joueur est qu'à infernale et divin ouais
moi que je vous dis je pensais à
baudelaire voilà quand je la voyais mais
moi je pense à rambouillet labrecque
sylverster stallone
[Applaudissements]
vous avez raison je crois qu'il ya du
dos sur géraldine aussi évidemment il ya
vraiment du dossier d'hier a dit jean
luc est ce qu'on peut se retrouver dans
un instant on se retrouve quand vous
voulez retrouver dans la soirée jean luc
reichmann avec christian avec alicia
avec mhd avec tony yoka et christian
vous avez dans des expos
oui moi je suis allé dans l'ain d'expos
et d'ailleurs je suis fan de rendez vous
en terre inconnue à l'heure avec un
train patience le prochain numéro une
habile à dans une bibliothèque on la
comprend au montalet bonjour luxe et les
questions qu est cher c'est parti
c'était déjà partis tout à l'heure
mais
je veux montrer un petit peu la
conversation entre valérie et mathieu et
donc niveau culture on avait besoin de
renfort donc géraldine est là pour nous
apporter ses connaissances dans
l'édition
enfin quand elle arrive à parler
regardez la galére c'est le fournisseur
officiel de l'elysée est ce que vous
savez d'ailleurs quelle est la
particularité de la galette de l'elysée
oui y'a pas de fait vient pas de faire
[Applaudissements]
quand françois hollande est venu dîner à
la maison c'était en janvier on a tiré
les rois nom et là on avait mis une fève
et ils étaient contents non ludique pour
lui la vegemite fèves genre est un vieux
on a le président avec des femmes vous
éclater la patrie fonds sur lesquels eu
la fève c'est elsa zylberstein qui a eu
la fève et qu'elle approchait audi qui
comme moi françois hollande non juré
jory la villa collège et une quote je
suis président chinois légal regardez
j'ai couru mais il n'a pas toujours été
président il pouvait être énervant
merci vous ne voulez pas je ne voulais
pas là la boulangerie ou en phase avec
une galette des rois sont aptes à
devenir non mais maintenant des
présidents avec nicolas sarkozy avait
déjà tiré les rois je sais plus d'accord
merci en tout cas vous soit vous avez
beaucoup de souvenirs dit merci
télex de louie louie louie lui la
brocante
[Applaudissements]
gavu peut-être comme ça c'est vraiment
joli
ah tiens le télésiège de l'amour cette
garde ne pas le prendre dans l'est alors
donc géraldine a apporté aussi pas mal
de bienveillance dans l'équipe kyle a
manqué la semaine dernière si reed et je
comprends mieux c'est après ce qui vient
de se passer avait soumis aux votes du
public l'entrée ou non de capucine sur
le plateau à celle que ça tout de suite
mis mal à l'aise
cgg première question que vous pose
elle n'est pas encore en tout la table
mais je les croise il ya un instant
capucines à naves
est ce que ça vous dirait que capucine à
face l'émission avec nous ou bien est ce
que vous dites
viendra un autre jour on attend de
profiter voilà donc oui non sur twitter
vous nous dites ethniques auxquelles
qui
[Musique]
un calvaire
il y a
mais tarbes à mesquer
ta fussent ils ont beau jeune et ça
s'est joué à % mais les gens roulent
good 1% 2% merci des pierres vous êtes
des capucines
je ne sais pas ouais je la connaissais
pas alicia belge il avait vite fait un
buzz sur secret story la corbeille si
jamais fait ce qu'il a dit à vous
regarder l'émission et lmh des
connaissances internet aussi mais à
l'inversé moment-là talent et sait pas
non plus si je voyais le faire la télé
mais son kit fait qu elle est mignonne
ouais je pense que poupée mais je pense
que vous pouvez que le style de capucine
qui est un peu vieux un peu vieux os à
vous et à 3 en plus dommage ses 19 ans
et 10 9 a passé dix-neuf lala
l'adénosine pas bien sérieux
jean lui vous connaissez capucine très
très bien et vous qu'il fallait répondre
oui j'ai déjà vu et là je la vois en
vrai de près les charmes d'accord
chavanon de christian et quand même
surtout les los un faux pas mon frère il
est venu ici et vous savez quoi le
troisième coup
[Applaudissements]
nouvelle question c'est très bien mais
marié non je suis divorcée et bien
christian faites vous plaisir et croyez
moi aussi mais recyclés et il se fait
plaisir on cherche on est dans la merde
ouais merci jean luc j'ai montré gili il
est comme méchant la semaine dernière
nous avons fait le jeu grèce maillage où
on avait classé les chroniqueurs parfois
mais malheureusement tout le monde
n'était pas là ce jour là
ap
je voulais pas rêver
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors maman je vous souhaite d'être
aussi beau et aussi svelte que vale
révéler les magnifiques mais je vous le
dit valérie vous êtes une bombe et on va
vous voir au ski vous verrez vendredi
valérie vous êtes de plus en plus belle
non mais sans déconner c'est vrai oui je
sais pas comment vous faites
ah oui ah mais je vous le dis non mais
vraiment si vous avez une recette donner
la vie tu connais la vita vous emballe
et non pas l'amour en refusant d'aller
se dire que les causes de la mort le
titre je sais pas pourquoi il est
hargneux comme sage il alors que s'ils
n'arrêtent pas de le complimenter
regarde et gilles verdez de plus en plus
bull
[Applaudissements]
je vous fais confiance une fois de plus
gilles verdez de plus en plus boon
[Applaudissements]
mais pas mhd n'est pas sympa ton poteau
si je pouvais changer de place et qui
charrie à l'école mais il sert il a bien
du mérite de tenir ses troupes
mais même s'ils se trompent parfois et
cette fois je voudrais rendre justice à
jean-michel la semaine dernière cyril
lui avait reproché devant tout le monde
de faire une mauvaise émission
et même si les prix sec le sourire ça
l'avait affecté le jean minot alors à la
pause il s'est confié son ami titille
toujours qu'il dise un truc comme
[Musique]
et
bon film ou les émissions sous le sens
mais des passants
ses copains on sent pas l'écouter
sentant les intérieurs
on n'a pas pris la défense de
jean-michel mais c'est vrai qu'il ya eu
quelques fulgurances étonnante à semaine
dernière et notamment campant dans les
chiffres de titi après qu'on ait bien
galéré il était le seul à trouver la
bonne réponse
on regarde les images ses 22 ans 22 ans
c'est l'âge de la dernière neuf de jean
michel maire
c'est un peu vieux pour savoir est ce
que c'est la condamnation d'une personne
cave vol qui a volé une télécommande aux
états unis oui mais bon aujourd'hui
et elle a trouvé celle là quand même un
pour un mec qui se disent on ne pose pas
mais je vous avoue que ça m'a surpris
alors j'ai fait mon enquête
[Musique]
même
que s'est-il passé ce soir là comment un
homme qui ne dort que deux heures par
jour vient par jour parce que la nuit il
fait la fête qui s'endort en regardant
c'est au programme avec sophie davant at
il pu trouver la bonne réponse alors que
tous ses amis et collègues s'y sont
cassé les dents sur resituer le contexte
son patron cyril hanouna leurs proches
de faire une mauvaise émission jean
michel se sent en danger
il sait que s'il ne réagit pas vite il
pourrait bientôt faire la fête 24 heures
sur 24
elle a tenté quelque chose comme
répondre à une question sauf qu hélas
les comme tous ses collègues ils
pédalent dans la semoule sur la question
de thierry moreau et c'est là qu'ils se
rappellent que lui et son ami sont
ventriloque qui peuvent communiquer sans
bouger les lèvres gentiment son complice
lui donne une bribe d'information donc
jean-michel vous allez voir va donner
une prime de réponse
c'est pas mal mais il sait que ce n'est
pas suffisant au qui va refaire de
ventriloque pour avoir la solution
regardez ce fonds d'essaimage édifiant
ses 22 ans 22 ans qu'elle n'adhère pas
du tout parce que là vous êtes dans
votre délire mais on comprend plus rien
oui qu'est-ce que ça concerne
l'enrôlement est ce que 22 ans la
condamnation d'une personne oui un peu
rapport aux médias oui car rapport aux
premiers indices commission juge en lui
vous êtes toujours dans l'émission
ah oui
[Applaudissements]
croyez savoir est ce que c'est la
condamnation d'une personne car vol qui
a volé une télécommande aux états unis
oui mais si bon aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
euh sa télé 7 jeux champions était dans
la merde quand il a fait but lequel reto
nil était mort de rire non et c'est
l'école ici sans déconner et celui qui
parle est venu meichtry vanille et
c'était magnifique
moi c'est un ami je vous sais pas rires
non pas comme ça mais sophie de maîtrise
et le fond de la classe là les deux là
les deux mais pas plus stéphanie et la
tête de thierry moreau qui a tellement
pas confiance en lui ce terme m on lui
donne la réponse est le regard mais aura
sera et comme ça fait quand il le suit
comme dans l'école des fans espèrent que
le muret demain quelle bombe dormoy elle
est le vent de la semaine maintenant
c'est celui qu ami cyril à jean michel
jean michel qui comme à son habitude
voulait faire un compliment bien lèche
bottes à son patron gros carton
[Musique]
c'est plus employeur
je
[Applaudissements]
ça fait du mal mais ça fait du mal bien
jean-luc on a un problème tant
qu'entraîneur facile
huit minutes weight l'atome un nom cette
langue vendredi oui est ce qu'on peut
continuer vendredi les gars ouais c'est
pas mon antenne c'est pas ma chaîne pour
moi ça aujourd'hui ace combat
est ce que c'est possible de comprendre
le faire vendredi au maire c'est
compliqué au niveau de l éditorial de
toute façon il n'y a plus aucune
cohérence de ce que je fais depuis tout
à l'heure un peu plus un peu moins
en plus moi ça me fait plaisir parce que
ça me fait plaisir d'avoir des quatre
tiers en plus vendredi dans la
quotidienne ça serait magnifique
oui eh ben on continue vendredi en
continu
[Applaudissements]